- I was in biology and science major.
I'm probably gonna get four right.
- So I have a minute to do this?
- [Offscreen] Yeah.
- How many problems are there?
60?
So one a second?
How come that took me so
long to figure that out?
- Ah, this is hard all ready.
Skip.
- This is crazy.
- Oh my God, I don't remember any of this.
- This is chump shit right here.
One times 12?
Get outta here with that nonsense.
- This is like Kuman from
fifth grade all over again.
- Oh (bleep) that, 12 times eight?
- I wrote down something
then I distrusted myself.
- Ah shit, no, that's not it.
I don't know what that one is.
- I forgot how to write numbers.
- Why is this so hard?
What?
- Ah!
- There's like no time.
- Oh, I'm cooking now.
Uh oh, no.
- Aw, shit.
- You literally just have to do it
in like the order that you see it.
- This is when you just gotta go.
- I'm like skipping a lot of them
just because I don't know them.
- Ah!
- No!
- Shit.
Oh my God, it's so fast.
- Okay, I'm happy with that.
That's great.
I felt dumb because I like
forgot what two times 11 was.
- Fine because I don't,
I haven't had to do multiplication
like that since third grade.
- 32 out of 60 ain't bad
in a minute, in my opinion.
My parents might just spank
me five times instead of 20.
- Oh, that's still an F, but yay.
- That's better than half.
The goal is to not embarrass yourself?
Then I think I succeeded.
- Ah, that's not great.
I mean...
- Yeah, I could have done better though.
- My heart is very heavy right now.
I (bleep) wrote 35 and then I wrote four,
and I'm like, "No you idiot."
I did not mean to skip three times eight.
That's easy, that's 24, duh.
- All right, I'll take it.
11 times zero is not 11.
I guess I still have some things to learn.
Shout out to Miss Hanson, third grade.
She taught me well.
- You have to know math.
You should know your
multiplication tables.
You should just know how to multiply,
divide, add, and subtract.
At least that stuff, you gotta know it.
You gotta know it.
Keith Habersberger endorses math.